raymond barre aux syndicats et aux
patrons avant le rencontre de mai une
véritable stratégie sociale philippe
sassier crise du pc georges marchais n'y
crois pas l'immense majorité du parti
approuve notre politique noël copains la
guillotine en question ont sénateurs
bonnefous propose de la remplacer par
une simple piqûre paul le faire les
enfant surdoué un congrès pour les
étudier ni génie ni monstre pire alain
messieurs bonsoir sur les bureaux
d'andré bergeron georges séguy edmond
maire françois ceyrac et d'une façon
générale dans tous les syndicats une
lettre depuis quelques heures et elle
est signée raymond barre c'est une
lettre de six pages dont j'ai ici la
photocopie qui propose un cadre de
négociations pour les semaines à venir
mais qu'ils jettent aussi les bases
d'une nouvelle politique sociale pour
plusieurs années que l'italie oui cette
lettre clôturé de façon assez
spectaculaire les rendez-vous que vient
d'avoir monsieur raymond barre avec les
différentes organisations
professionnelles les syndicats et le
patronat l copieuse journée de 10 et
précise elle fixe n'est cadre de
discussions et de négociations non
seulement pour les semaines qui viennent
c'est à dire hors immédiatement aussi
pour les années à venir ouvriers c'est
noka documents à s'est un peu repris
hier soir détaille laurent détails sous
les 4 grands thèmes sont abordés dans
cette lettre
premièrement l'emploi deuxièmement les
rémunérations les conditions de travail
et la participation
alors si vous voulez bien quelques
points de détail à l'intérieur de ces
quatre chapitres l'emploi réductions
reconduction pardon du pacte national
pour l'emploi dans les quinze jours qui
viennent le ministre du travail va
recevoir les syndicats pour discuter
avec régime des de chômage il faut
discuter de leur simplification demande
monsieur raymond barre politique
industrielle les syndicats vont être
tenus au courant non seulement des
décisions mais des propositions sur la
réorientation de l'industrie française
qui seront faites dans les mois qui
viennent et enfin des problèmes globaux
de l'emploi on faire l'objet d'une
réflexion un peu de réflexion roches
mais entre les différents partenaires
sociaux et le gouvernement les
rémunérations alors là le principe de
base c'est là que la hausse des
rémunérations doit être dit
ancien et négocier qu'est ce que cela
signifie différencier cela signifie que
les bas salaires doivent augmenter
beaucoup plus vite que les hauts
salaires et que petit à petit l'éventail
des salaires en france doit se rétrécir
négocier cela signifie que donc chaque
groupe
on va discuter des possibilités de
hausse des rémunérations
ces négociations sur les rémunérations
vont s'ouvrir dans les semaines qui
viennent
à la fin de l'année on va faire le point
et le gouvernement pourrait proposer au
parlement une modification de la loi sur
le smic
vous voyez c'est quand même très
important troisièmement les conditions
de travail là il ya des négociations
demandé par le premier ministre au
niveau toujours des brancards des
secteurs industriels sur la retraite sur
les congés sur le travail posté vous
savez c'est le travail concernant les
fameux 3,8 et le gouvernement souhaite
renforcer dit monsieur raymond barre le
rôle des conventions collectives
enfin la participation la ligue 1 un
passage important retenir le
gouvernement présentera au parlement un
projet de loi sur la représentation des
cadres au sein des conseils
d'administration ou bien les conseils de
surveillance des emplois alors la
signification politique de tout cela si
vous le voulez bien c'est un petit peu
le dernier volet de la stratégie de
monsieur raymond barre les premiers
volets de la stratégie sow qui valait de
la liberté liberté de gestion pour les
entreprises liberté et vérité pour les
prix et enfin ce volet la relance d'une
politique contractuelle mais à la
liberté plus grande place aux
entreprises il ya un contrepoids et bien
souligné dans la lettre du premier
ministre le premier ministre entend
effectivement fixer les thèmes de
réflexion et de discussion des futures
négociations alors très rapidement les
premières réactions des syndicats très
rapidement parce que syndicats disent
qu'ils sont en train d'étudier 2009 4 6
pages quand même assez important alors
le au sial tf pour lyon grâce à un petit
peu des dents on dit que s'il doit y
avoir une politique contractuelle et
bien les règles du jeu sont à fixer des
règles du jeu est à la discussion vous
parlez par les partenaires sociaux et
non pas par le gouvernement ce que vient
de faire monsieur bart et puis comme
monsieur bart libère d'abord les prix
entreprises publiques avant des prix des
entreprises privées voyez vous au cnpf
on est un petit peu amer chez lavinia
ouvriers mais ça dit que
ouvriers et faut essayer sans que les
racks automne assez positive notamment à
cause de la participation des cadres qui
fait plaisir à la cgc chez les caps
enfin la cgt bien on dit notamment que
la politique d'austérité n'est pas
modifiée par est à dire de cette bien
cette revalorisation des bas salaires
dont vous parliez viendra à point pour
aider les faibles revenus à mieux
supporter les fortes hausses annoncées
pour lundi prochain os dont je vous ai
déjà donné le détail hier à l'edf au gaz
de france a la sncf fo ptt et pour les
tabacs la ratp c'est pour un peu plus
tard à partir du 1er juillet
retenons aussi un fort accroissement des
cours du boeuf ce qui va se traduire
dans quelques jours par un distec
beaucoup plus cher les cours de la
viande bovine ont en effet augmenté de
10 à 15% depuis dix jours mais tout cela
n'est pas comptabilisé dans l' indice
des prix de mars publié aujourd'hui 0 9%
c'est ce que l'on attendait c'est un
mauvais indice due en partie à une forte
augmentation de tous les services qui
gravitent autour de l'automobile
enfin la dernière augmentation augmenter
celle d annoncer par dans sept des
cotisations de chômage
ce matin l'unedic qui est l'union
nationale de l'emploi dans l'industrie
dans le commerce a décidé de porter son
taux de cotisation à 3%
il était jusqu'à lors de 2 4% coûts
supplémentaires 3 milliards de francs
cette machine n'est pas avare de ses
sous de son écriture saccadé automatique
elle signale à sa ble ment d'échec à la
vitesse de 6 100 à l'heure et ses
cadences déjà fort va devoir s'accélérer
il y avait en effet six cent mille
chômeurs allocataires assedics en mars
dernier ils sont six cent quarante mille
pour ce mois d'avril une croissance
rapide qui ne va pas sans conséquences
financières le montant global des
métiers de chômage est passé de 625
millions 69 à près de 11 milliards de
nos francs
dernier et les réserves au supplice
c'est pour cela que ce matin les
représentants des patrons et des
syndicats qui gèrent égalité l'unedic
ont décidé de faire passer les
cotisations plutôt de 2 40% à 3 % ce
taux s'applique à la masse salariale est
répartie pour les 4/5 sur les employeurs
et pour le 5ème restant sur les employés
ainsi un salaire de 4 mille franc
entraînera une cotisation de 24 francs
pour le salarié est de 96 francs pour
l'employeur une hausse donc très forte
qui symbolise la difficile financement
d'une protection sociale
chaque jour plus étendue mon problème du
financement de la protection sociale
collective deviendra la question sociale
la plus importante dans les années qui
viennent
protection sociale collective ça veut
dire la sécurité sociale les retraites
la protection du chômage les allocations
familiales et c'est heureux on constate
un déséquilibre entre le nombre de ceux
qui versent et le nombre de ceux qui
reçoivent des prestations alors la
grande question qui va se trouver posée
quelle est la part du salaire que les
gens accepteront d'économiser je vais
centre guillemets pour se prémunir
contre tous les aléas de l'existence
qu'il s'agisse de la maladie de
l'accident du travail du chômage de la
vieillesse etc etc
en d'autres termes ça va déboucher sur
un choix fondamental sur un choix de
manière de vivre
un choix qu'il fera faire rapidement en
se quittant ce matin le bureau de
l'unedic a décidé de se retrouver
en juillet pour décider très
certainement d'une nouvelle hausse du
taux des cotisations la politique
maintenant avec d'abord et surtout la
deuxième journée du comité central du
parti communiste car contrairement à ce
que l'on pensait il y aura une
prolongation demain je rappelle qu'il
s'agissait essentiellement de discuter
le rapport marchait à georges marchais
qui demeure ferme sur ses positions 1 le
parti communiste ne porte pas la
responsabilité de la défaite de la
gauche de 19 mars de l'immense majorité
du parti est d'accord avec cette
politique alors voilà les textes
officiels dont le copain essayons de
lire un petit peu entre les lignes
et d'abord cette réponse aux
protestataires réponse très dur mais
l'europe c'est pas la peine de lire
entre les lignes il est très dur la
réponse est cinglante parfois ironique
je vous cite simplement cette phrase
avoir le plus grand souci de la vie
démocratique est une chose
démanteler les parties au nom d'un vague
anarchisme petit bourgeois est autre
chose et bien et monsieur marché précise
qu'il n'y aura pas d'ouverture de
discussions dans les colonnes de la
presse du parti avant celle qui est
prévue normalement pour le 23ème congrès
après c'est un troisième congrès qui
décidera s'il faut ouvrir des tribunaux
discussions alors deuxième accusé le ps
est là aussi le réquisitoire un site web
c'est un long réquisitoire sur les six
années de 72 signature du programme
commun jusqu'en 78 défaite de la gauche
hélas la condamnation est sans appel le
parti socialiste porte la pleine et
entière responsabilité de la rupture et
des chaînes quant aux particuli s'il a
commis aucune erreur
eh bien on peut dire que tout ce rapport
tente à justifier à maintenir la ligne
du parti communiste est justifiée
effectivement monsieur marché reconnaît
nous ne disons pas que tout était
parfait mais notre ligne a bien été
celle de celle ci celle de l'union de la
gauche nous n'avons commis aucune heure
alors comment est ce que tout cela
prépare l'avenir et bien l'avenir pour
monsieur marché c'est l'application est
il précise le développement des thèmes
du 22e congrès d'il ya deux ans le
socialisme aux couleurs de la france et
changement démocratique
avec une telle force sur laquelle il
insiste beaucoup c'est à partir des
luttes quotidiennes et c'est à partir de
la base que l'union doit se faire il
maintient la stratégie d'union de la
gauche mais cette union par la base
paraît déborder lui honda gauche et
tendre vers ce que le parti communiste
déjà pelé l'union du peuple de france
neil copains j'ai tjrs là bas toute la
journée
quelle était l'ambiance est bien je veux
dire est que dans ce très bel immeuble
fait de verre et de béton c'est deux
jours si c'était davantage le béton que
le ver n'y avait pratiquement aucun
contact entre la presse et les membres
du comité central
si bien qu'il est difficile de savoir
quelle était l'ambiance deux indications
quand même et qui compte la première
c'est ce qu'a indiqué tout à l'heure il
semble que les discussions étaient si
ample qu'il faille la poursuivre demain
et puis deuxièmement malgré l'ampleur de
cette discussion il y à nous at on dit
unanimité autour du rapport de georges
marchais alors comment s'explique cette
unanimité je crois qu'il ya trois
explications possibles la première
serait celle de la direction il n'y a
pas de crise en tout cas la crise n'est
pas ce que la presse a dit qu'elle était
deuxième explication qui serait celle
donnée d'avancé par les contestataires
le comité central n'exprime pas la base
il exprime la direction et puis
troisième réaction que métro mais un
militant aujourd'hui qui prêtaient une
réaction de défense
le parti est attaqué de l'intérieur de
l'extérieur on serre les rangs autour de
la direction le parti une nouvelle fois
à rester du ps en revanche on ne peut
pas tomber dans le même travers si je
puis dire que le pc à la veille de la
convention nationale du ps qui s'ouvre
samedi l'hebdomadaire du parti d'unité a
ouvert ses colonnes aux représentants
des principaux courants et sous courants
du parti
en revanche pas de commentaires dans
l'entourage de françois mitterrand à la
suite des rumeurs selon lesquelles il
serait candidat lors de l'élection
présidentielle de 1981
c'est le journal le matin qui avait
lancé l'information en précisant même
que françois mitterrand aurait confié
ses projets à valéry giscard d'estaing
lui-même ce qui étonne beaucoup la
lettre de l'unité de georges fillioud
voilà pour les affaires politiques
la situation au tchad maintenant près de
200 français pour la plupart des femmes
et des enfants de coopérants sont
arrivés ce matin à roissy ont déclaré
qu'ils n'avaient reçu aucune consigne
individuel pour quitter le pays mais que
cela leur avait été conseillé de dire
que nombreux sont les français à s'être
inquiétée de l'évolution de la situation
là bas
le pr lina t'a appelé pour deux jours à
la grève générale et à des
manifestations dit jaguar français ont
atterri tout à l'heure dans la capitale
djamena pour le ministre de la
coopération il s'agit d'une action de
dissuasion un petit peu comme celle
menée en mauritanie
destiné à protéger donc la vie des
français du tchad pas débat tendu il
s'était engagé ce matin au conseil de
paris adp a convoqué un conseil pardon
provoqué par jacques chirac lui refusait
d'augmenter la contribution de sa ville
aux charges de police à l'unanimité
moins
six abstentions les conseillers de paris
ont donc dit non à l'état qui voulait
inscrire 142 millions de francs
supplémentaires au budget de la ville de
paris rien ne distingue a priori un
fonctionnaire de police parisiens d'un
de ses collègues de province
sinon indirectement la participation de
chaque habitant au budget de
fonctionnement de la police cette
contribution varie selon le nombre
d'habitants de chaque ville et est
proportionnel à la population de la
commune
ainsi chaque habitant des villes de
moins de 10000 habitants payent zéro
franc 44 par an pour les dépenses de
police
cette participation augmente
graduellement suivant le nombre
d'habitants des villes pour arriver à un
maximum de 3 francs 30 par habitant pour
marseille et lyon paris est un cas bien
particuliers en effet tous les ans une
somme forfaitaire est fixé par le
ministère de l'intérieur
cette année elle est de 292 millions de
francs soit 126 francs par habitant
si l'on divise cette somme par 2
millions 300 mille parisien on est donc
loin des 330 payés par les marseillais
et les lyonnais ce litige de la
répartition des dépenses de police entre
l'état et la ville et est aujourd'hui au
centre des discussions du conseil de
paris
fallait-il sommé par le préfet revenir
sur une décision prise en décembre sur
proposition de monsieur chirac
devait-on accepté de payer 292 millions
au lieu des 150 déjà voté par un vote
les conseillers ont répondu non les
lève-tôt samus excellent joueur
si j'ai pu respirer sans voix nous
arrêter
50 était sûr de la délibération
s'enquiert contre 0 mais le dernier mot
reste à l'état qui va inscrire son
chiffre au budget et qui contraindra la
ville a trouvé des ressources sous forme
probable d'impôts locaux
cette affaire prend des dimensions
politiques dans la mesure où elle tend à
démontrer que le maire de paris monsieur
chirac n'a pas des pouvoirs absolus mais
elle prouve aussi que comme beaucoup
d'élus locaux les conseillers de paris
souhaite une réforme accordant plus de
pouvoirs aux collectivités locales
on voit que si la ville est
indéniablement défavorisés par rapport
aux autres grandes villes de france sur
le plan de la police elle est par contre
avantagé sur le plan des sapeurs
pompiers d'une manière sensible d'une
manière plus sensible encore sur le plan
des affaires culturelles et d'une
manière considérable qui avait
d'ailleurs suscité dans le passé de
nombreuses interventions de députés de
province à l'assemblée nationale en ce
qui concerne les transports parisiens
si j'ajoute qu'à tous ces problèmes
s'ajoutent ceux de l'aide sociale vous
concevez que ce n'est pas en quinze
jours ni même en deux mois que l'on peut
arriver à trouver une solution au
problème qui consiste à faire entrer
progressivement la ville de paris dans
le droit commun des rapports entre les
grandes cités et l'état la peine de mort
à nouveau en question en fait le débat
est reposé différemment par un
parlementaire le centers bonnefous et
comme edward bonnefous sent bien qu'il
est difficile d'aller contre l'opinion
il propose tout simplement d'essayer de
réfléchir sur une suppression de la
guillotine
mais pour la remplacer par quoi est
parti du chaffaut est un moyen dépasse
et qui a perdu d'ailleurs son caractère
d'exemplarité et qu' il rend une
sentence qu'il doit être exécuté de
façon à mon avis trop inhumaine qui est
que l'on peut parfaitement remployer de
nouveaux moyens notamment les
médicaments qui peuvent être mis en
corps humain sous forme de piqûre donc
pas ce qui aurait évidemment pourrait
faire je ne dirais pas de rendre moins
inhumain la sentence que l'échafaud mais
le correspondent plus à l'évolution de
la pensée moderne
en somme vous voulez substituer au bout
de l'échafaud le bourg ou infirmiers le
bourg ont affirmé vous savez entre le
caractère de métier de bourreau qui
consiste à trancher la tête ou à faire
une piqûre ne vois qui apparaît comme
une mesure et que un bourreau pourrait
plus facilement faire une piqûre que
tranche la tête ça me paraît très en
deçà plus conforme à l'évolution de mon
actuel pour finalement pas le faible
c'est c'est un problème politique
puisque autre chose lorus lois que
l'évolution vous disiez tout à l'heure
du nato bonnefous va même si ce n'est
pas son intention première ouvrir le
débat de la peine de mort au parlement
faris coeuret de le faire car il est
loin d'être sûr que nous verrons demain
on accepte que cette question soit
inscrite à l'ordre du jour pour
l'instant la majorité
la plus grande partie du monde politique
dans son ensemble n'est pas favorable
personne ne veut prendre le pays au
fonds à contre courant et parlementaires
disent qu'ils n'ont pas été élus sur le
dossier de la peine de mort ou sur son
abolition
et qu'il faudrait sur ce point organisé
une consultation particulière une
formule autres d'ailleurs que le
référendum qui selon est aussi question
ne doit être utilisé que pour une
réforme des pouvoirs publics alors
personnellement je n'y crois pas pour
l'instant
quant à la suppression de l'échafaud
bien les abolitionnistes vont dire le
célèbre et niall de la piqûre est
finalement aussi barbare le cérémonial
du couperet et les partisans du swat du
statu quo et leur côté vont pouvoir
ajouter à leurs arguments
celui-ci puisqu'on veut humaniser
adoucir la peine de mort est bien c'est
une raison de plus pour ne pas la
supprimer
et voyez vous pour le faire j'ai appris
aujourd'hui que le procès de michel
rousseau qui était condamné à mort par
la cour d'assises de douai et bien et
cassé par la cour de cassation donc
michel rousseau sera rejugé valéry
giscard d'estaing demain à lyon pour
inaugurer le métro un métro qui va
changer beaucoup de choses dans la vie
des lyonnais
beaucoup de choses en profondeur bien
sûr mais aussi en surface pour cette
agglomération de 1 million deux cent
mille habitants
bernard pradines voici lyon et son
agglomération une agglomération dans la
particularité et être à grande densité
de population ici le rhône la saône le
centre de la ville de ce côté
villeurbanne là en rouge le tracé d'une
nouveau métro avec ses stations en noir
à métro qui dessert le centre de lyon
ainsi que le centre de vie normale à
métro ultramoderne dont l'incidence
principal a porté sur la qualité de la
vie des lyonnais une meilleure qualité
de la vie grâce au métro lui-même ce
sera plus agréable de traverser la ville
en 17 minutes plutôt qu'en une heure du
temps gagné sur les loisirs le métro de
lyon et très peu profond il est donc
facile d'accès les stations sont
pratiques
le train lui-même et d'une technologie
extrêmement moderne télécommande
automatismes
il roule sur pneus en silence n'est ciel
sont larges et confortables
les accélérations progressives et
l'esthétique très bien étudié le système
de surveillance et de sécurité est aussi
très moderne peu de personnel et en
matériel sophistiqué
les ingénieurs ont également pensé aux
conducteurs nous conductrice le poste de
pilotage est à la fois précis et
reposant le métro de lyon et économique
ils consomment peu d'électricité
il a coûté moins cher au kilomètre que
le rer de paris deux fois et demie moins
cher financement l'état 20 % le reste en
emprunts gros inconvénient tout de même
le prix du billet il est cher deux
francs 80 mais un système d'abonnement
permettra de bénéficier de réductions
pendant les cinq années de construction
les lyonnais ont eu des doutes devant
leur ville éventré et déchiqueté la
compensation c'est un réseau tout neuf
de canalisations pour le gaz
d'électricité ou le téléphone
c'est aussi et surtout un nouvel
urbanisme dans le centre de lyon
plusieurs places de la ville ont été
refaites des quartiers ont été
remodelées entièrement enfin beaucoup
d'espacé a été conquis au profit du
piéton au coeur de lion deux grandes
avenues sont devenus rues piétonnes et
les rues piétonnes c'est l'animation la
rencontre est souvent la fête
le métro attend 130 mille voyageurs par
jour
il répond à un besoin ancien lion veut
se moderniser mais aussi vivre mieux
occupation depuis deux heures maintenant
des locaux la société provinciale des
ateliers terrain à marseille la
direction venait d'annoncer que la
totalité des salariés d'avril des
salaires d'avril pardon ne pouvait pas
être payé car le groupe connaît de
sérieuses difficultés à l'étranger
maintenant un accident dramatique aux
états unis en virginie occidentale un
échafaudage s'écroule il était à 60
mètres de hauteur 45 ouvriers qui
travaillaient sont morts sur le coup
j'ai bien dit
quarante cinq 45 au moins me dis là ne
me disaient de la dépêche
en italie la guerre des nerfs se
poursuit avec un nouvel attentat des
brigades rouges
elles ont frappé cette fois un cadre de
l' usine fiat à turin toujours la même
technique de tir dans les jambes
cet attentat est un avertissement
visiblement destinée à faire pression
sur le gouvernement et l'opinion
publique
quatre jours après avoir réclamé la
libération de 13 terroristes et bien les
ravisseurs monsieur moreau ne se sont
toujours pas manifestés coup d'état en
afghanistan un coup d'état qui semble ce
soir avoir réussi et qui a renversé
l'homme en place le président daoud fait
la force dépasse le simple problème
intérieures d'un pays dans une région
très sensible de par sa situation
géographique au confluent de trois
mondes région charnière par excellence
l'afghanistan vient brutalement de
changer de chef le prince-président
daoud que nous voyons ici à delhi nous
allons voir un instant à moscou a été
renversé par le général et bientôt
président abdul kadir ben nul ne possède
jusqu'ici le portrait il y a eu toute la
journée une bataille de chars assez rude
dans la capitale kaboul sept cent
cinquante mille habitants où la
tradition veut que les hommes nous le
verrons dans un instant se promène tous
ou presque
ar mais même lorsqu'ils ne sont pas
militants
il semble que le général khadir soit à
la tête d'une fraction gauchisante de
l'armée afghane dans sa première fois
comme nation il annonce que les derniers
vestiges de la dynastie de nadia quand
renversé en 1973 seront supprimés si la
victoire des putschistes et confirmer ce
qui paraît le plus probable à la fin de
cette journée
les observateurs estiment que
l'afghanistan aurait alors tendance à se
rapprocher politiquement de son voisin
soviétique
arrivé il ya quelques heures à
strasbourg du chancelier schmidt et
helmut schmidt était l'invité des vins
l'assemblée parlementaire du conseil de
l'europe
le chantier allemand devait y recevoir
des mains de madame louise bresse le
prix international de la fondation
baisse ce matin à notre confrère les
dernières nouvelles d'alsace a publié
une interview à laquelle le chancelier
faisaient une véritable profession de
foi atlantis en affirmant qu'il n'y a
pas d'europe possible sans la protection
un mec dernier acte de la tragique comme
il dit bruxellois ce qui est devenu un
véritable feuilleton je vous disais hier
on avait volé le manneken pis et bien
non seulement ne l'a pas retrouvée mais
encore on a volé la réplique en plâtre
qu'on avait mis provisoirement à sa
place et je vous promets de raconter la
suite
parlons maintenant des surdoués pour la
première fois en effet en france
un congrès international sur l'enfant
surdoué se tient ce week end à nice le
surdoué c'est un enfant d'une
intelligence précoce mais ce n'est pas
forcément un génie il n'est pas
forcément non plus toujours premier de
la classe en fait ils posent des
problèmes à ses parents et à la société
en général
tu dois quand même avoir une méthode non
fou mais encore pour trouver un
concentrons pour trop vos stéphane à six
ans et demi son jeu favori le pull en
dix minutes ils assemblent 100 pièces
sans se servir du modèle il fait partie
de ce que l'on appelle les surdoué un
terme ambigu
nous vous pourrez vous dire c'est un
enfant que les tests d'intelligence ont
dédié comme si vous aimez les
intelligences et très grossier c'est
très imparfait vous savez je vais vous
faire une réponse beaucoup plus simple
tout ça un enfant qui a 4 ans sait lire
et écrire centre personne mais jamais
appris il ya bien quelque chose de
particulier ya pas besoin de tests ses
seins l'enfant surdoué et c'est plus
fréquent qu'on ne croit quand je dis
fréquents intentions moins quatre ou
cinq enfants sur 1000 sur dix mille
selon les cas mais enfin c'est une chose
qui se trouve tout de même pour les
parents dont certains se sont regroupés
en association l'éducation d'un enfant
surdoué pose deux types de problèmes sur
le plan affectif il a les mêmes besoins
que les enfants de son âge
intellectuellement en revanche il a une
sorte de boulimie que l'école ne
satisfait pas toujours il est rentré à
l'école maternelle
quatre ans tu es quand j'ai voulu comme
j'ai demandé s'il commence à le savoir
lire quand j'ai demandé à ce qu'il passe
dans la classe maternelle supérieure 10
on la mettra la galerie ce ci refuse
elle m'a dit qu'une était très en beauté
pas du tout des bourgs dit qu'il était
absolument pas capable de passer en
classe de maternelle grande classe de
maternelle et que de toute façon on
arrivait à apprendre à lire un enfant de
deux ans quand on y mettait à patience
alors dans ces conditions j'ai arrêté
guillaume aura bientôt 18 ans il devrait
passer son bac dans deux mois mais
plutôt que d'aller en classe ils
préfèrent travailler dans un bar pour
pouvoir voyager du trône et profond nuit
énormément
pourquoi pour beaucoup de raisons pour
la bonne première raison que ça
m'intéresse pas c'est c'est banal c'est
aberrant c'est stupide
guillaume est un enfant que j'ai j'ai
rencontré la première fois alors qu'il
avait 11 ans et qu'il était sur le point
de se faire mettre à la porte d'un
collège pour indiscipline parce qu'il
était trop tôt ni trop actif parce qu'il
supportait mal ce rythme ralenti
convient posée
c'était je m'en suis aperçu ensuite un
enfant extrêmement brillant qui aurait
pu être brillant sur le plan scolaire
mais qui avait évolué vers un
comportement assez destructeur à
l'époque et pour lequel il a fallu
absolument trouver une autre solution
scolaire que celle dans laquelle ils
étaient insérés c'est le problème soul
et du décalage qu'il y avait chez cet
enfant entre ce qu'on lui proposait ce
qu'il aurait pu faire
est ce qu'il aurait voulu faire
permettre l'épanouissement du surdoué
tout le monde est d'accord sur les
moyens d'y parvenir en revanche il y a
ceux au nom de la démocratie qui
refusent l'idée de lumière d'une serre à
matière grise
d'autres qui souhaitent un enseignement
spécifique à ce type d'enfant
et bien c'est toute la question n'est ce
pas en réalité il s'agit d'un enfant
handicapé
alors là j'ai oublié de le dire mais il
faut que j'insiste lourdement là dessus
il ne s'agit pas d'un enfant d'un bon
élève il s'agit de quelque chose de plus
qu'un bon élève le bon élève à se
débrouiller
là il s'agit d'une sorte de génie il est
aussi fragile est aussi handicapé qu'un
enfant débile retardé mental et pour des
raisons opposées voyez vous alors ce
qu'il faut faire pour là je trouve que
pour des raisons éthiques il faut le
faire pour les autres
sans négliger ni les uns ni les autres
c'est à dire est qu'il faut créer une
fabrique de génie par exemple
n'égaleront monsieur charmant mais du
point de vue éthique
écoutez est ce qu'on a le droit de tuer
mozart
samedi et demi après demain direct de
nice sera consacré à ce problème des
surdoués avec de très nombreux invités
autour de jean paul ii mangeons
constitution d'une commission denquête
au sénat sur les conditions du naufrage
de l'amoco cadiz il ne s'agit pas
seulement de faire le point sur les
choux mans mais de tirer des conclusions
positives pour l'avenir sport maintenant
si vous étiez devant votre petit écran
hier vous l'avez tous vu sur la pelouse
de furiani transformé en bourbier via
les corses ont dû concéder le match nul
devant eindhoven vous êtes tous posé la
question fallait-il jouer sur ce terrain
détrempé
cette action offensive de bastien résume
en une minute elle seule ce qu'a été
cette rencontre est le véritable
calvaire qu'ont vécu les joueurs corses
et ceux d'eindhoven
le fait de jouer de ne pas jouer ce
match était la seule décision de
l'arbitré lee burke avenue maksimovic
mais il faut savoir qu'au delà du
terrain d'autres considérations entrent
en jeu d'ordre financier tout d'abord si
un match est annulé lui arrêté avant la
fin de la première mi temps les
spectateurs doivent être remboursés
recul été aussi nombreux cet après-midi
qu'hier soir
ce n'est pas sur lui un match décalé
c'est par voie de conséquence ce
calendrier du championnat qu'il faut
changer
et ce n'est pas simple c'est peut-être
pour cela qu'un match de coupe d'europe
reporter est un fait rarissime en tout
cas ce n'est jamais arrivé pour une fine
et on voit que l'intérêt sportif passe
souvent pour ne pas dire toujours
après le reste hier soir à furiani les
joueurs corses n'ont pas pu faire la
différence ou même eindhoven ils n'ont
pas encore perdu cette coupe de l'uefa
oui cela dit si le match avait été
reporté à aujourd'hui antenne 2 l'aurait
bien sûr retransmis demain commence le
premier grand week end mais beaucoup de
bouchons en perspective alors si vous
partez respecter ses conseils partait de
préférence dans la nuit de vendredi à
samedi
et si possible le vendredi avant 16
heures sinon ne prenez la route que
samedi après-midi le tiercé de ce jeudi
se disputait à auteuil la combinaison
gagnante et le vin de 2 le 8 et le 4 je
n'ai pas encore les rapports vous les
aurez dans le dernier journal
les prévisions de la météo pour demain
sur la moitié nord du pays
beaucoup de nuages avec quelques pluies
éparses sur le reste de la france le
temps sera plus variable avec des
averses notamment sur le centre et dans
l'est
dans la journée le temps s'améliorera
sur le midi et sur l'ouest aux alentours
de 23 heures 20 après le grand échiquier
c'est gérard holtz qui vous présentera
la dernière édition je vous souhaite
tout dans toute l'équipe d'antenne 2 une
excellente fin de programme
bonsoir à tous à demain